um speaking of Donald Trump in his
interview with Fox News
it was rather hilarious for many reasons
let's play the clip of this a portion of
his interview so we've freed it up we
freed up this country so much the miners
and energy and the banking system is now
coming to with dodd-frank which is a
disaster
we freed up so much and we getting great
great credit for it we have done so much
for so many people I don't think that
there is a presidential period of time
in the first 100 days where anyone's
done nearly what we've been able to do
and on top of it we just had during the
first 100 days a Supreme Court Justice
approved not just nominated but approved
through a very very hostile environment
I am I'm really shocked that either he
doesn't know where he doesn't care I
mean I could think of at least 40 other
examples of presidents getting more done
in the first 100 days probably 43 who've
gotten more the other one would be the
president that died after getting
pneumonia at the inauguration William
Henry Harrison area the longest
inauguration address in presidential
history refused to wear a top hat
because he didn't think it looks
presidential ammonia and died in 30 days
yes so I think he might be the only
person who didn't get more done than
Donald Trump but Donald Trump clearly
has not accomplished half of probably
anything that he said in that clip the
only thing he actually tangibly
accomplished was the nomination and the
confirmation of Neil gorsek which only
requires the nuclear option but it's not
as if he didn't try you pushed for the
health care bill that would replace
Obamacare he pushed for a travel and
Refugee ban and given the fact that he
had both houses of Congress on his side
you'd think he'd be able to do a lot
more than just push for a Supreme Court
justice and even that they needed to use
the nuclear option
right exactly so you know it's it's
actually good he did try and some of the
things that he tried were deemed
unconstitutional which is great for
America great for humanity but in terms
of legislation he did more with
executive orders which is hilarious with
Republicans who who always accused
President Obama of ruling by edict but
this is exactly what Donald Trump did
but in terms of legislation
he didn't get anything done he has Elise
on his website his 100-day plan he has
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten pieces of legislation that he
wanted to get passed including the
repeal of Obamacare and he's gotten none
of that done and compare this to our
most recent recent president President
Obama by his 100 days he was able to
pass the stimulus package he was able to
pass the lilly Ledbetter and by April of
2009 Obama had an approval rating of
something like 63% yeah where is Donald
Trump's approval rating right now is
anywhere from 35 to 40 percent but you
can't tell him that according to him
he's been the most productive president
in the first 100 days
never mind the president from whom we
got the entire phrase of the first 100
days Franklin Delano Roosevelt who
passed the majority of the New Deal in
the first 100 days Donald Trump seems to
not recognize history our our he doesn't
care about it this is a bit of a stretch
but you could say that Harry Truman
defeated the Nazis in his first hundred
days compared to Donald Trump woo you
know I don't know how are we grading him
on a curve I think we're grading him on
a curve like as well so long as he
doesn't destroy the planet in the first
100 days he's gonna be considered a
decent president it's just he doesn't
deserve to be graded on a curve because
as I said he has the entire government
behind him yeah he has majorities in
both the House and the Senate and now
with Gorsuch on the court he has an
advantage there too right exactly and he
still can't get it done